perfect
[Music]
what's up guys welcome back to the
dope's usual podcast I am Thomas
dobizola this is Marty O'Neal what's up
let's go it's been a minute I feel
awesome I feel good today too guys let's
get straight into it this episode you
guys have been bugging me in the DMS
ever since we talked about it this is
Sean solo Franklin fontino Fontina I
knew I was like yo I'm gonna mess that
last name up I know I'm going to man
um how you doing man I'm good brother
I'm good thanks for being here man to
link up with you man it's been a long
time yeah it's been a long time I mean
I've been keeping up with your [ __ ]
since
last time I saw you I'm always on top of
everything so I'm seeing everything
you're doing I know you say you have a
book yeah so
let's get straight let's get into that
first because I want everybody to know
about this is it it's dropping wait just
dropped right oh in January oh we put we
pushing it back man to win for a couple
weeks
yeah okay do you have a date yet well
I'm a no I'm gonna have a date actually
Wednesday they just waiting on me to
pick a date oh I keep listening this
month yeah I keep pushing it back man
because
um you gotta hold on let me
you gotta remember that um
this is my life story so you just can't
rush that out to the world because once
it's out there it's out there you can't
do anything else about it nice man it's
out there bro it's out there
oh [ __ ] and a graphic novel of my life
bro a comic book this just the first
chapter what man I'm not playing with
them brother yo this is everything from
your life this is my real true life man
it's the real stuff yo this is tight
let's go
yeah so this drops at the same time yeah
if you look and say no
yeah I say no I'm right the first
chapter in the book is called numb
so every chapter I'm gonna do one of
these with it so you gotta buy each one
to get it or you can buy the collective
of them all oh [ __ ] the everything this
is smart man it's like a collector's
it's a collector's item visual it's a
visual like a storyboard yeah I love
this yeah damn oh it's getting graphic
that's why I said so look this is um
not to cut you off from interviewing me
but no tell me this is the um this is
the this is the rough one this is the
very first book that I did so I keep it
I hold it because
it got [ __ ] in here that I I actually
erased in the real book that's coming
out man because when I first started
doing my book I started pouring damning
everything I've been through and then I
started weeding out [ __ ] afterwards
because that's the only way you can do a
a true book to where people will like
understand it and love it so
this is the book that has all this [ __ ]
that probably could put me in [ __ ]
jail put me in some [ __ ] trouble all
kinds of [ __ ] shows yourself so I'm
finna burn this [ __ ] like I talk
to my attorneys and everything I didn't
say a whole lot of [ __ ] that I could
have said but it's just it sits with me
uneasy so I haven't been through this
book
thousands of times it feel like
and hitting my partner up saying hey
take this chapter completely out because
I was talking a little too much and then
take this out
um
um like the Ice Cube chapter in here you
take that out nah I made them I fixed it
you know because
what was the it about like
um I really just didn't really even want
to talk about the Ice Cube chapter I got
a good friend man his name is emery
um he's like Jake one of Jay-Z's
right-hand mans you know Roc Nation and
stuff he's my boy and I went and sat
down with him you know up at Rock Nation
and we was just talking and we had
personally friends
and I was saying I'm doing my book man
and he was like man that's gonna be hard
just based off of my life story so
um and I was saying what do you feel
about the The Ice Cube chapter you know
I kind of didn't want to talk about it
but I do he was he was telling me nah
man don't put that in here bro no just
move on past that because you bigger
than that bro you got Rockstar you got
Grand Theft Auto don't let that hurt you
so
I put it in there anyway don't [ __ ] us
because no because it is part of my my
history
is something that I hate that I did but
it ended up being a big part no idea
what you're talking about right now me
and Ice Cube got into it and I took his
West Side connection chain bro be real
it's all on YouTube bro let's be real
hold the West Side connection chain
we got history man you know I won't get
too deep in it because I want people to
read that [ __ ] yeah this is the game
changer man the shirt you can get it you
can read about The Love Story between me
and him because that's actually my
friend you know I'm talking about really
my my friend me and Cube go way back we
just had a misunderstanding it was a
fight a little bump and bumping and that
was it bro then we me and him cool to
this day you know what I'm saying so you
got to read the book man but just
remember I'm not glorifying any violence
in here bro that's what I went back and
I fixed just so people aren't saying
like oh like you just said glorifying
like oh yeah I did this to this fool now
look at me I'm fine yeah to anybody yeah
to anybody that I've ever had an issue
with in my life I don't want to glorify
it in my book I don't want to be the
villain I've been the villain all my
life man I want to be the hero I want to
be loved I want people to feel me read
my book and understand what I've been
through like
um just a quick little something out of
the book you know um
I've been through two kidnappings that
don't nobody know about well a lot of
people in the city watch know about it
my wife who I'm with now she's been
kidnapped because of me um my son mom
been kidnapped because of me because I
was in the streets I was getting my
money yeah and
that comes with the territory that
[ __ ] no matter how hard you is I
thought I was untouchable
but it goes to show you not because I'm
from I'm from Watts La you got Compton
you got Carson you got the the West Side
South Central you got Gardena you got
they give two [ __ ] about how hard you
is in that city right there you feel
what I'm saying yeah of course so I come
up in the era that when
gang banging was tied in with big drugs
crack
Colombians sitting moving on your
blocking flooding you with drugs like
unimaginable drugs brother you know what
I mean yeah you're a young kid and you
you got access to kilos and [ __ ] like
that bro and you like what the [ __ ]
where'd this come from and you making
money over money over money and you're a
kid you feel what I'm saying so I come
from that era then you had the jackers
and the and the robbers and the
kidnappers that came and got the dudes
that had the big big money so I was
raised up in that era when shoot first
asked questions later you know how
somebody might rob you for something and
say hey take that off and they give you
a chance to take it off and give it to
them I come in and where it was just
doom doom and they pull it off a dead
body like I've been shot I've been shot
several times I got if I pull my shirt I
got staples running all up my hair
bullet here here because I went like
that after I've been shot and being
robbed at the same time
so I come up in a shitty era man you
know I'm thankful I made it through it
yeah very thankful sounds intense oh
intense wasn't you gotta remember we
didn't have cell phones like that we
didn't have security system where we can
watch it make sure nobody comes to your
house so you was just bare ass you come
out the house you just had to be yo your
head had to stay on the swivel like at
the gas station yeah so I stay at the
gas stations yeah I got a call from one
of my brothers that did federal time and
he said he was in there with an inmate
that
said that he thought I did something to
him back in the days right and he was
like man I hate to say this to you bro
but I was trying to get your brother he
was like ever every day he came home
he got out the car he had a bulletproof
vest on he had a pistol in his hand and
it was a dude came out on the second
story of where I lived at with a gun on
top of it that's how I came home every
day that's a militant lifestyle for real
no this is true story bro that's how I
had to come home every day and he said
man I could not get him we used to sit
in the bushes we was going to kill him
and my brother was like what
you know kind of getting mad like they
ought to [ __ ] you up right now yeah yeah
that's my brother you know what I mean
but he was like bro I found out it
wasn't him after but in the first few
two three attempts we were trying to get
him but every day he pulled up all we
heard was like
and and I was making sure I get in the
house that's the life I live for for a
few years man I've been through some
[ __ ] brothers that y'all wouldn't
imagine you know and it's in my book man
you know 16 17 year old you know raising
myself uh never knew my father you know
my mother was in and out of my life my
grandmother raised me so you know I got
introduced to selling crack and
um I only got a ninth grade education
they let you stop going uh they didn't
like track you down to keep going to
school nah bro
okay okay now you go to jail your
parents go to jail for that [ __ ] yeah
nah back then they didn't give a damn
bro you know but you couldn't make me go
back at that time because you know I'm
that young and I'm selling crack and I'm
making money so yeah I said yeah it's
like you you you're gonna have to damn
it drag me out of these streets to get
back into learning about some [ __ ] I
don't give a [ __ ] about you know because
all I remember was they was trying to
tell me George Washington chopped down
about that man and then I come up in the
city
I went to a Gompers uh junior high
school in Locke High School
um where
they were teaching us
fourth or fifth grade work from a good
school and we were equal grades like if
I'm in the seventh grade I was getting
fourth grade work that people were
getting in the good schools like Beverly
Hills and all that so they were keeping
us behind that's keeping you down a
little bit keeping us keeping us yeah
you feel me if you're in the 12th grade
you you study in ninth grade work from
another good school so I I care too less
about
um the educational part but I push it on
kids a lot like you know I sometimes man
I did uh panels uh places where I went
to schools and talked to the kids man
and I and I and I push it man stay in
school please you know go to college do
this and do that and it's good that we
do that because we want the kids to stay
in school but the schools have to start
teaching these kids the right [ __ ] our
system is pretty bad the system is
horrible you know you want us to push
the kids to stay in school and get
education but it's kids out here that
don't got educations and went to college
got degrees and everything and they
still [ __ ] working in Starbucks
because we live in the it's not what you
know it's who you know world it's true
like you know I oh I can hire you
because you're my homie are you my
family member they're not looking at
this educated person right here who the
company really needs to come and sell
and help the company Excel and be a good
good worker no they're gonna hire
somebody they know so now you got these
kids coming out of colleges man
depressed you know suicide and debt and
debt you feel what I'm saying doing
things that they really didn't want to
do you know what I mean so
um I pushed going to school but also I
push that real [ __ ] too man you know
yeah and it's school for structure yeah
and it's time that these corporate
buildings man y'all start hiring the
right people man and stop letting your
manager hire all his family and that's
that's where it's at right now you know
what I'm saying so yeah it is all about
who you know we were just talking about
this it's all about who you know it's
not about what you know yeah because I
know some people that own companies my
how the [ __ ] you don't run this company
yeah you're incompetent but I see it
every day it's yeah all right but it's
not my business I'm Gonna Keep moving
yeah especially in the [ __ ] weird
world oh
[Laughter]
are you a 35 year old dude in jeans and
flip-flops right now you got money year
now we'd invest it that's pretty much
how that works yeah
um
so
uh the chapters you were talking about
is mainly in your book so that's one of
my questions where'd you grow up so
Watts you're growing up open wise and if
you're selling crack I mean I was doing
this not crap but I was selling wheat
you couldn't get me to go to school if I
grew up with no money at all and now I
got 30 dollars extra yeah yeah I'm not
coming to school today it's like it's
not I don't feel like it's our faults
it's more of like the opportunities
there do you want me to wait till I'm 21
to not be hungry all day it's not going
to happen yeah I can't do it not gonna
do all my friends are eating and [ __ ]
I'm going to sell something yeah the
structure has to change it has to bro I
don't know if it's gonna ever change
they ain't gonna think so they ain't
gonna fix something that's working for
them
you know get your kid to come to these
colleges and we're going to put your
parents in debt and the kid in debt
that's the whole thing is to keep us in
debt I'm so glad I'm not in debt I don't
oh [ __ ] that's the worst my credit card
I pay that [ __ ] off and
sometimes I just stop using them because
I rather pay for what I want man yeah I
totally understand that is very
stressful that's why I was at school
because they don't teach you this [ __ ]
that means something in life yeah yeah I
don't know how to do the checkbook yeah
it's got me for [ __ ] 10 years you
don't put any of this [ __ ] on me
then they say they gonna forgive [ __ ]
the college loans but they won't like I
got someone that's in in my family I
ain't gonna say their name but they kid
went to college did great but all the
debt went on the parent now the only way
they forgive the debt this is the crazy
part this is the weird [ __ ]
she has to continue working until she's
60 something she can't retire now that's
the only way they forgive you so we're
going to keep slaving you and stuff
yeah it's modern day sounds like third
world country cartel [ __ ] come on bro I
never heard of that you have to keep
working till you're 60. that's the only
way we'll forgive the the interest that
you've been accruing all that [ __ ] yeah
schooling for a couple years to come
back yeah so then you wonder why
you know people lean towards doing other
[ __ ]
I mean it's like this get a degree and
make that money or maybe in debt or I
can go sell this right now because we're
gonna lose our [ __ ] house too if
we're going to get evicted I don't have
food I got some [ __ ] to pay for it I
mean it's it's a no the people that
don't understand it the people have
never been poor before exactly and even
if I was never poor I could still see
the [ __ ] side for of it yeah like you
got nothing no money
I would Rob some [ __ ] too yeah yeah
there's nothing else to say I get it
it's a cold world I get it man I
understand but it's just
there's nothing how are your parents
feeling about all those growing upwards
my parents wasn't around man my mom she
had me when she was like 16 15. so she
couldn't raise me so my grandmother
raised me and by my grandmother raising
me
um
I was able to have more space
my chain was like really took off click
you know I didn't have a us I can only
go so far out the yard no click go
because this is my grandmother you know
she's old-fashioned she's just same with
me the lights are going down just come
back yeah that's how my grandma was we
can start start coming back yeah like
you know my grandmother she she was my
everything man that's that's the love of
my life man you know I got they they
names right here tatting on me my mom
and my grandmas they both passed so
um ages you know my grandmother would
just let me go like she would whip my
ass with a with a I got a whooping with
a peach tree see people don't know about
that [ __ ] go out there and get that
Branch off the piece oh switches a
switch Yeah she will whoop your ass them
little things sting man they hurt bad so
I remember your clothes yeah I remember
my 14 year old 13 and it's in here I ran
away
and
she just went on about cooking dinner
because she knew I bring my ass back
that's the old-fashioned mentality of a
of an older person yeah the
grandmother's mother father they're
gonna come look for you and being beat
the [ __ ] out of you for a minute they're
gonna be worried because they're gonna
come trying to find you because they get
worried a grandmother is like
that's a good way to put it that's
exactly how my grandma was he'll be back
I ain't worried about him I've been
through this [ __ ] many times I know you
know they old school yeah and plus when
you have the older grandparent it's
really cool it's it's very I know you do
this it's very easy to I'm gonna go with
my friends and then the second you're
out you're a [ __ ] Menace yeah and
then it's like you come back
everything's back to normal and they
have no idea what you just did some
manly as terrible things would you say
she was aware of all this crazy [ __ ]
going man my grandmother was aware oh
she was beyond aware she let me do it
um she let me do it man and I hate to
say that but you know my grandmother
just was that type man she was like I
just love
all my kids and grandkids I was her
first grandkid grandson period my mother
was the first to have a kid and she was
just like long as you do it well I could
see you doing today if you're gonna sell
something sell it right outside of my
house wow so that kind of [ __ ] me up
too but at least she kept me kind of
like at least I'm trying to keep him
safe because he's going to run off and
do it if I didn't say yes the police
will come raid and looking for the crack
and hiding and she would come outside
and be cussing my ass out that's and she
worked every day my grandmother had a
good job lucky yep she used to get in
her car and go to work come back home
cook for us and everything but she still
was about her kids and her grandson
she was very he had a good upbringing it
sounds like at least you had someone
there that cared for you well I had a
great upbringing because I was raised by
my my three uncles and my grandmother
and my grandfather like I said my mom
she was still trying to figure her life
out because she was young you know when
I finally got back with my mom
I was able to buy her a house
I bought her her first house that's so
cool I was
18 19. damn Oh I thought you're gonna
say that this is more recent at 18 you
bought the house I thought my mom her
first house you were crushing it then
yeah was she what was she like she like
astonished like what though these kids
you know she she knew what I was doing
and she knew I was doing it so you were
in like loose contact yeah and and she
lived on the East Side in my old gang
banging neighborhood and uh
it was her and my little sister
and I remember just I don't want y'all
over here no more
you know come on
and I put her in a a nice apartment
first on the west side of town the
better side of town
um they stayed there for about I want to
say about two three years I'm paying all
the bills everything putting my sister
through school two at the same time
um and I'm young myself and I'm doing
all of this I'm taking the
responsibilities at 18 19 year old right
so
um I end up getting into it with some
dudes in that area well I didn't my my
crazy ass brother did for nothing and it
turned into Gunplay so I said you know
what let me get them up up out of here
because they did come back and shoot the
place up so I ended up saying look just
find something we gonna buy it so she
found a house cause you know we come out
the ghetto she found a two-story home
with a pool and she was like I want this
one right here and this and that what
you want okay
put the money down the failing man
that's you know I mean here you go let's
go do it and when the guy with back then
you know you can you can just fill out
some [ __ ]
get him a down payment and they give you
the house that's where freeway record
time yeah you don't have to go yeah
everybody wants cash yeah Rick is like
like my play Uncle man oh no [ __ ] when I
tell you I was getting money when I was
young it's like now now it makes sense
you bought a house
area like you know the Rick is in the
book and everything oh no [ __ ] all right
all right so damn you question it at
that time that's my OG that's so crazy
man that's such an accomplishment to be
able to move them out like that at that
age it's unreal it was it was it was
easy
it wasn't just me you gotta imagine
whatever I was doing it was other little
young dudes doing it 10 times more
because it was just so easy when the
crack era hit through all the black
areas because that's all it really hit
in black and brown areas
the money was just like like walking
dead the zombies just keep coming coming
they go find the money and they just
keep coming it was turning
doctors and people that had degrees and
good jobs into uh strawberries and
Junkies you know I'm talking about
overnight you know they on their way to
work with a doctor shoot on and
everything but they stopped down the
street and say look I don't have no
money today because I've been buying it
all week can you just give me something
and I I'll come back and pay you next
week or that turn a favor and if you got
a young horny dude and it's his friend
moms
that's it was [ __ ] up bro and and they
knew what they were doing the system
knew what they were doing when they did
what they did bro but I came up in that
time when it was [ __ ] up man
plenty of money
but but but hell to come with it you
know what they say Mo Money Mo Problems
true story that's true so true
especially how we were getting it
standing on Corner because you're
getting the money from the people you
turned into zombies yeah and you know
these people you know it's heartbreaking
you know them every day you seeing them
and they they selling [ __ ] to go get
twenty dollars twenty five dollars ten
dollars you know what I mean and I I if
I say
if you ask me would I do it all over
again hell no some [ __ ] in my life yeah
I do it all over again
but that
if I could have did if I could have just
been around a family of hard-working men
that had good jobs
and was teaching real estate uh teaching
you know how to construction truck
drivers curious Styles yeah teaching me
your hairstyles great [ __ ]
description you know what I'm saying
Teach can teach me some other than
what I was doing my uncles would would
[ __ ] gangsters that's all I saw it
man you really didn't have an option
though I didn't have too much of an
option the only working person was like
at that time was my grandmother
she can't teach me no because she
teaching me I don't even know what she
was doing when she left to go to this
big ass building it was called Lockheed
I thought they was making locks I don't
know what the [ __ ] yeah but she had an
honest job now my uncles they had honest
jobs but they still was in the streets
and they was with that gangster [ __ ] you
know I mean so these are the only three
dudes I saw and then all day friends
pulling up in rolls royces in front of
the house and Cadillacs and everybody's
[ __ ] each other yeah and they
accepted me as the little young dude so
it was like easy for me to fall into
that [ __ ] because it was in my face
every day that and it's super appealing
these schools aren't poor no that's all
you got to say nah they aren't these
guys aren't [ __ ] hoping to get [ __ ]
for rent yeah that's all you any look at
any third world country too though
anywhere even my [ __ ] where I'm from
Merced it's all meth the only people
that got money sell meth yeah that's it
the Cowboys like all their cartel guys
all right never mind yeah scary guys but
that's how it is like once you see
someone that's not poor what are you
doing to not be poor yeah I need to get
on that yeah so when I came up it wasn't
a Mexican cartels I didn't I didn't know
one I didn't know nothing about them
um like I said it was Colombians they
came and they came and you if you listen
to Rick's story
you believe that Rick is not lying man
Rick was Rick was the go-to guy to
everybody you know speaking on Rickman
Rick was a different breed if we had
more uh Ricks out there
like when he was hustling and doing his
thing if we had a lot more of them we
would have been in a lot better place
because Rick wasn't flashy yeah
definitely if I never knew him I would
have like get your crackhead ass away
from me hey you want to watch my car
that's how Rick carry himself
you know what I mean yeah no I get you
so if we had more people like that
we would have been in a lot better place
Rick talked
um
you know you don't have to show your
money
that's what people that's what I got
from just watching this guy you know I I
just remember a lot of [ __ ] man when he
had the big Palace of Wheels man I had a
Mustang and I don't know if it's on a
picture in here somewhere but he put
rims on there for free Dayton at to be
exact you know I never forget that and
um he you know he did he did for the
community
you know they had a park over here off
of uh I want to say Hoover Street
in in the 90s or the 80s somewhere up in
there man he refurbished the basketball
courts you know he was a real different
breed of a person you know to be driving
around in Rose races and all that crazy
[ __ ] I never saw that if he had him I
never saw it because I wasn't around him
all the time I met him through
Affiliates of the guys that I was
working for my ogs you know what I'm
saying so when I met him I was just like
wow you know it's the dude I never would
have thought just the dude and I never
would have thought you know I'm
expecting to go see somebody with chains
hanging everywhere big gazelle glasses
Heisenberg he's the Heisenberg yeah
there you go yeah the description yeah
man you on point you're on it today man
yeah but
but he's he's a different breed man so
whatever he got coming to him like fame
um success and I see he deal with the
marijuana the medicinal business and
stuff the legal way and everything so
whatever he has coming to him man it
should come to him in tenfold because he
went through a lot of [ __ ] that he
probably shouldn't have been through but
the system oh he he let us know a little
bit and just a little he told me I was
[ __ ] shocked oh like this [ __ ]
happens not in just movies but to you oh
no all these movies man that I see on
the streets man they based off of this
dude right here man yeah it's because of
him that the [ __ ] branched out of Los
Angeles into all of these other states
and cities man you know the gangs went
out there all these hoods got started
places because this guy was so helpful
oh [ __ ] I always wondered Like Houses
all these LA gangs all over the country
they just branched out of L.A when
people leaving from here to go hang out
with their cousins in other states
they get it popping out there and then
he could be from East Coast [ __ ] 60 [ __ ]
Hoover and then now he's starting it out
there with the dudes them country dudes
out there in Arkansas and now you from
60. all right yeah yeah that's how it
starts it goes franchise it because they
know somebody it's a family member that
goes somewhere now I can't even say
exactly how Rick was involved with any
of that but I'm just using the story of
that he was a very like
helpful person if you needed help you
would get it so I'm just saying that to
say if I needed help just say if I was a
hustler and I was running out of town
I wanted to go start something out of
town I can go to him at that time you
know that's all I got I need some help I
want to start it could possibly happen
here kind of your business man do what
you got to do and then I take off and
get on the plane and I go somewhere now
I'm making I took whatever I took that a
little bit made a lot of money and then
turned these dudes into my neighborhood
now
you know but it put it also put a lot of
dudes in jail
it comes with it it comes with the
territory so all in all like I said I
have
zero thing to say negative about what
Rick did because Rick was just he was a
guy that was just caught in the system
man and he he broke the code and he made
his own combination he was talking about
thinking he was like reading the book
that the dude that started Walmart wrote
he was trying to think like Think and
Grow Rich he wasn't worried about the
gang banging and [ __ ] he was trying to
franchise and any of that [ __ ] yeah any
of that [ __ ] he was well respected by
everybody not just
somebody or these dudes no I'm talking
about everybody like is there only a
couple people in La gangbang and
politics like that I would imagine
that's like transcend everything
um
if it is I don't know like Nipsey I
would think yeah yeah you can give that
to nip yeah I don't I don't know enough
to speak on it beyond that but yeah it
doesn't seem like Yeah from from what I
from what I've heard
yeah you can you can probably push it
down he was trying to really do that up
the day before he died legitimately yeah
but it was a lot of it was some more uh
Ricks out here I just don't know him it
was some guys under the radar you never
knew nothing about you thought he was
just had a job cleaning the streets he
was the richest dude around but I don't
know yeah but I'm just telling you from
what I saw with my eyes
how Rick carried himself man I can
honestly say I never ever ever ever saw
him like
like just zoomed up trimmed up real nice
cleaned up wool jewelry cops don't look
at you when you look like a regular guy
yeah but and ain't no other people too
they don't
but it's these these cowards these
weirdos that when they get banged up
that's where it goes um got you they do
whatever they got to do to save their
own ass yeah you know I mean it's not so
much worrying about I'm gonna get caught
selling some [ __ ] it's more about uh who
saw him he saw some [ __ ] who knows what
I'm doing yeah I just feel like
it's not people in suits or in in
uniforms all the time you got to be
worried about nah especially when it's
when you're in your neighborhood doing
this [ __ ] and envy is the worst thing in
the planet yeah and that's what gets
people shy every day even though they're
not doing nothing wrong yeah there's
other people like well I'm broke he's
not I don't [ __ ] like that yeah and
that's just the life we live in now bro
but it sounds like he didn't have the
ego where he gave a [ __ ] like he was he
was playing tennis and [ __ ] he didn't
give a [ __ ] about what everybody was
caring about and Rick just wanted to
just help that's what I saw he just
wanted he just like I said he just
masterminded some [ __ ] and he wasn't
stingy he was not stingy at all he was
just like eat if you everybody could eat
let's eat let's let's just eat eat how'd
you feel about the Rick Ross the rapper
exploiting them like that because that's
been a big topic on the show I I don't
get into that part I bet it was weird
when I heard
you know Rick Ross from the Rick Ross I
knew I remember I never met this Rick
Ross in my life don't know nothing about
him but when I heard this rapper Rick
Ross came out I just took it like
do he know Rick that's when he brought
it up like they must know each other he
must have gave him some money I'd be
like no you can use it yeah that's what
I thought for many years like oh Rick
must the co-sign because that's just not
a name you come hey wait come on man you
can't just take it you come up with a
with a with a with a a Grand Master
Flash or you come up with another kind
of name you know what I'm saying but a
Rick Ross and that's not even your name
nowhere close to your wrist it's like me
being a rapper my name is Pablo Escobar
now yeah
I can see if your name was your last
name was really Escobar that's different
yeah or your first name was Pablo then
that's different but dude this man had
no affiliation to that name so come on
man like I said Rick was
Rick was a a he he is that at that time
he was like an icon man he was like I
think his name was just ringing so tough
in places that you never could imagine
I'm only speaking on what I think I
don't know yeah I thought he had a life
sentence though that's why I can imagine
yeah I can imagine
in Florida to say
I'm really popping man yeah come home
tap into that whole Legacy of his [ __ ]
like how I mean like how Rockstar did
with you he took his [ __ ] likeness
yes yeah but he's a person they're with
you yeah and you knew about it yeah man
come on man that's like a dude from L.A
coming out with I'm a uh
what's a big this name a drug dealer
from from New York I don't even know
yeah I'm trying to think what are the
dudes from Paid in Full yeah there you
go perfect just say uh a dude from um la
he start rapping and that's his name
Alpo um what's his last name uh Martinez
or something Alpo Martinez but the
dude's a corrections officer to begin
with you see what I'm saying so so it's
like it's a sitcom come on man do your
thing but also
um so back to where we were
18 19 by the house you leave
how did you go from doing what you're
doing
to getting into acting like how did this
transition come because you I know you
know DJ poo obviously that's a that's
how we we met with Donnie and everybody
that's how we kind of
but how does that happen like that's
just what you just said you know like
how do you know how do you know like did
it start with the wash because we I just
blew my mind I got that's one of his
favorite movies
um nah it was it was way way before that
man DJ Pooh um is like man he's a legend
in in in in the business I don't want to
just say in LA and California he's a
legend writing the business of
entertainment and he need to get his
just do his props he need anything and
everything that he want all his
accolades everything he need that man
because this man is so giving
I talked to him almost every other day
and his heart is just like you know like
my heart is is guarded
so many people can only get there
this dude heart is just open it's like
you cut him open and just set his heart
out here and it's just beaten and he
just like meant to take a piece of it I
don't care that's just how he is that's
why I love him so much because he's just
so giving and how I met him was crazy
man I want to tell y'all but like I said
oh don't don't give it away then don't
give it away man it's gonna be in the
book man and y'all gonna be the first to
get it soon as I get him I'm gonna have
a bunch of them like I think in about
two days but um
is is is crazy because we're gonna have
to come back and do another interview
once y'all get the book Because You're
Gonna want me to come back all right I
already know I promise you but yeah I
met him I met him through ice cube man
okay like I said early 90s yeah duh
early 90s like 1991 I think I want to
say 89.
no [ __ ] because Cube
Cube was still with NWA
he started
um Street knowledge in about 90 91 92
somewhere up in there about 90 because
he signed Cam and we put Peachtree out
in 92.
um oh [ __ ]
yeah man I said Q um mom and dad used to
live on the same street uh the house
that I bought for my mom oh [ __ ] so I
used to see Cube
and that's how we became you know he's a
Jerry curl Q with yeah with NWA
and so uh that's how our affiliations
start coming but when he finally got
Street knowledge I used to hear about DJ
Pooh with the uh the uncle jams Army and
king T in the king T was they did the
album together dropped that bass Dunes
that's the first time you heard of it
yeah DJ Pooh did all of that man DJ Pooh
is a legend bro and I tell you man he's
a legend that do not get his props like
he should get when I say DJ Pooh a lot
of people go DJ boom like
I mean how do people not [ __ ] know
this [ __ ] as soon as you say something
he did then like oh like yo you remember
really got socked in the [ __ ] mouth
that's the first thing like oh like
that's the direct man that's he need his
stuff man like I'm here on y'all show
man to give him his roses man where the
camera at which one oh and I love you
man you know I love you dude I'm giving
you your roses from my heart bro let's
go you know what I mean yeah he's such a
cool [ __ ] man he's a really nice dude
every time I've talked to him very cold
so that's how I got tied in I met him
through Ice Cube and we kind of went off
on the left side like I said some stupid
to him and I was a tough dude at that
time kind of stocky and I I said some
disrespectful to him and
I didn't think he had come because he
was a skinny guy I didn't think he would
come and address me and he came and
addressed me like a man and I could have
took it to another level with him but I
couldn't do nothing but respecting
because he was right I was wrong
after that we became friends are you
testing them or was it just random try
to test him I tried why they try to test
him I tried to actually act like I was
punking like I was bullying
him and a few more people in the studio
at that time they were doing the Lynch
Mob record and Q was doing death
certificate oh [ __ ] and I was in there
acting like I was trying to bully you
know what I'm saying and um
pool came out and set me straight I I
take that he came in he put me in my
place in a respectful way but in a hey
I'm a man I ain't no [ __ ] punk
I'm from somewhere too you know what I'm
saying yeah I'm Affiliated too do it the
right way yeah yeah so I respected him
and then ever since after that man it's
like we've been tied together so he's
like the Spike Lee of the West Coast
because it's a good way to put it that's
a great way to put you think about all
the people tied to his movies and
everything so many cult classics after
Colt classes
uh Chris Tucker y'all could see a lot of
people don't know he had a lot more than
just being in Friday
he had a lot to do with Friday he's one
of the creators oh no no I know but I
know about the history of the Friday so
it's like
well when I when I met him in person I'm
here I'm having lunch with him and
Donnie and we bring up GTA yesterday
yeah I haven't seen him in so long
he's still dealing with uh Kobe he had
cold oh [ __ ] and he'd been hitting on
him now but he's doing better now
um but he's cool I talked to him he's
getting better it's been so long but
yeah that's that's when I realized like
when I said something Grand Theft Auto
and Don he's like you know I played the
voice and if I see and go all right
Donnie what the [ __ ] you talking about
and then I saw DJ Pooh's face I'm like
I'm gonna stop tell me everything you
guys are talking about and that's I'm
like what do you mean you're part of
Grand Theft what are you talking and
that's how I found out what he's doing
the writing and [ __ ] I had no idea I
mean that's my favorite game of all time
I own that and Madden that's it I don't
own any of the games so that's when he
brought when I realized like yo you are
the culture of everyone loves it but how
does nobody not know this [ __ ] yeah like
how did I not know it's my favorite
[ __ ] game ever yeah you know so like
you're saying like I think he doesn't
get us enough he don't man because he
pulled me in you know he put me in the
first thing the first project he ever
had outside of music because y'all might
know that y'all might not know that
um cam the rapper cam k-a-m he had a
song called where all the East Side
Riders at whoop whoop that was him he
was big cam was big at the time
um me and cam was together a lot from
Tomorrow a lot who orchestrated the
album with us uh and then he was doing a
movie called uh
uh three strikes
I was watching that movie phase alone
started getting his dick sucked my mom
went nope turned the TV off that's I got
five minutes into that movie picked up
the girl she's on the table I never saw
the rest of it yes that's the movie that
I was in and I had I was on the
soundtrack if you look at the soundtrack
we had a song called where I come from
me and Kane you're acting and having a
song in it and I never did any of this I
never raped and I never act but Pooh
just had faith in me and he just seen
some of me and he was like man you're
gonna be in this movie and you're gonna
play this dude yeah so you have no
active skills you said all right no
rapping skills no nothing get in the
studio he had a studio called digital
Shack that everybody recorded out of if
you name him you name any name they'd
have been in their recorded albums out
of there it's new anybody you name it
um
who was like man look you're gonna play
this dude named Mo Big Mo
and it's at the end of the of the other
of the movie uh when he go to jail at
the end of the movie and three strikes
and he come in and he run into me
um
after that
um who like he did the movie The Watch
and
I I was one of them persons that I
always was round I always was around
because Pooh was just so cool me and him
that grew like brother brothers
and I was always around man and and I
didn't even have to ask for it man it
was just solo I got a role for you I
want you to play this role I walked in
the casting studio in the casting office
and boom my picture is up there for a
guy named face
remember it was slamming face the
kidnappers and I'm like damn so I didn't
think much of it I said well I'm just
gonna have a little bitty roll you know
a little tiny roll in there that's cool
he keep looking out there and it ended
up turning into me and him still in the
show
you know he's the idiot crazy fool and
I'm the serious man quit saying my
[ __ ] name on the phone I just can't
believe you were you I was like no how'd
you feel though like walking in no
that's what I said like he's a lot
smaller now because I was tell cause
that's one of his movies
like you know he's in the wild what the
[ __ ] before you got here so he's like oh
he's way bigger back then yeah yeah you
look so
how are you feeling walking in going oh
[ __ ] this is real my pictures up here I
have to be in this movie now it's still
don't hit you until
you you tell well you know when it
really hit me man with the with the
watch was
when
doing scenes with Dre
and being around all these these these
Shaquille O'Neal exhibit Eminem Snoop
all these actors man you know I'm saying
George Wallace if you remember man the
wash hat everybody Alex Thomas you name
it was in the Chong everybody was in
that movie so being around them it still
don't hit you
but when he hit you is when we went to
the first uh the screen
and setting yourself up on a [ __ ]
screen yes sitting there
and finally seeing yourself because I
remember when you're just filming
you don't see the movie you can't Vision
that this is a movie you just doing a
scene like me and you right now they got
it the the puzzle piece yeah he has to
go put the [ __ ] together and make it
look good so when you finally seen it
that's when they hit me I was like God
and people laughing at me and him like
in this in the in the theater like
I was like damn and then years later
it's a classic and I'm part of a classic
so he he just kept it coming man and
then he called me after that
um to come lend my voice in San Andreas
with um my cousin melee who played CJ in
San Andreas oh [ __ ] yeah that's my
cousin yeah so yeah
I didn't I didn't realize CJ was best
not a real person too yeah young melee
man I was wondering he played he played
CJ man so that's a different experience
though just going in headphones talking
just talking just you have to express
with your voice so it's actually a
[ __ ] yeah what's up [ __ ] Grove
Street you know [ __ ] like that you know
how many times I've quoted that [ __ ]
yeah every time I get home I go Rose
Street yeah I say it Rosie gets so like
all right man it's been 10 years of this
[ __ ] like I know at least it was so I
[ __ ] everything up you've heard me say
it
uh so you walk in there you have to
actually act with your voice when San
Andreas comes out you obviously don't
get to know what's going on and then the
story lines is coming out and you're
seeing I brought up to Marty it's like
well we'll get into that how are you
feeling when I mean you're playing the
game you're seeing the game played
this is written about just stories like
how are these missions make I know
they're I know it's it's dialogue it's
story it's
are these missions just people that are
like you know what happened to this
happened to me one time let's throw it
in the game like how does this it's
interesting from the perspective of an
actual like La gang banging dude like
because it's dirt it's about the whole
culture yeah I always wondered that like
how do you feel about this crazy well
San Andreas was like come on man that's
the best game of all [ __ ] time
the second I got on that bike yeah it
was the first game me too man the
documentary came out I was in the
[ __ ] buffalo in a blizzard the dog I
had the documentary going GTA on the PS2
the new thin one I was out here yeah I
was in another world yeah man it was it
was different man just just being a part
of that and you know I I thought I was
the crazy part about it is you you after
you do something you just move on in
life yeah and I didn't do nothing major
on there I just land my voice and I used
to try to find my voice on there you
know like there I go right there when
they say hey fool what's up [ __ ] I like
that's my voice but melee is CJ Carl
Johnson so you can imagine how he was
feeling and I was so happy for him
because this is my god this is my cousin
you know like man I'm happy for my
youngster man he he he he did it you
know he got San Andreas under his belt
and um how'd they find how did they pick
him to be the like man DJ pool man okay
he's your connection for all this right
Jake who is the connections for all of
his it's not like he he give you
anything he just gives you opportunity
to come get it those are the biggest
people as an entrepreneur those are the
biggest people that come in and put they
recognize put you in the spot like solo
melee all y'all hey just come read for
this [ __ ] then when you get there it's a
whole bunch of other [ __ ]
reading that you don't even know or Pooh
might not know but
you end up getting it and it came and it
don't always be on pool influence like
me with GTA
he called me it's in the book he called
me to come in and read
and you know I said damn the character
is supposed to be a 24 year old
character
how how am I supposed to do this and I'm
in my 30s at the time you know what I'm
saying I'm like man I don't want to do
that [ __ ] and I'm seeing all these young
younger cats out here 20 some and all
that
and I end up Landing a row I end up
getting a call from Rockstar because
it's out of pool hand once he gets you
yeah they have to gives you the
opportunity like hey if you crush it you
got it yeah they have to hit you like
um they call me back for a second
reading and that's when I met uh slink
met his crazy [ __ ] the tallest
[ __ ] I ever met in my life
[ __ ] touch the roof is that
Lamar yeah
he's a whole
uh he's a whole show himself man
um but I met him
and um
it was like it was a match made in
heaven with me and him but
we still didn't know what we were doing
it was just you know Pooh unders under
ndna himself oh she just get destroyed
he didn't say this is Grand Theft Auto
with a video game it's a video game this
company is doing this company is doing
it I didn't even know it was Rockstar
again yeah so when we finally get to do
it they gave me said that I'm gonna play
a character named Desean
and the game is called Paradise
so I'm like damn I'm gonna be in a video
game called Paradise or I'm gonna go try
out for a video game called Paradise so
what happened was we did it I get the
second call back read it and then after
that you know a few weeks after that the
director of from Rockstar which is the
director of Grand Theft Auto and
miniseries he calls and say hey how
would you like to how would you I mean
how you how would you
it was some way like hey like welcome
you coming to New York how you feel
working with us for the next year and a
half or something like that that's what
it was kind of like I mean are you cool
with that I was like [ __ ] yeah I get a
chance to get out the streets because at
that time you know I was going through a
lot of [ __ ] man I was um
man right before uh
me filming GTA five
man I was I was a [ __ ] up bro yeah
bro I was a [ __ ] up I remember my wife
used to just be telling me you got to
get away from these guys they're gonna
put you in jail I'll kill you they
weren't gonna kill me I was gonna end up
oh you were still [ __ ] with
everything I was still just in the
streets not with the drugs no more after
the movies you're still [ __ ] with
them I was in the streets on some
taker type [ __ ] if you had it I wanted
it I'm coming to get it by any means
necessary
and my crew we was not no joke
so I was running the streets real tough
one selling I stopped selling dope when
I was young man you know after I had my
run with that when I was in my early 20s
and and the [ __ ] kind of went went went
bad you know what I'm saying uh
um
I stopped I just said you know what I
took losses like I said it's in here
you're gonna read it and you're gonna
see why it I hit a major depression time
in my life
I'm talking about it was the worst
feeling ever to go from a high to a
complete bottom low not just a low I'm
talking about two are complete
of a a April can I borrow like five
dollars man like and you a guy that was
out buying houses for your mom buy you
had all the cars you got all the money
you helping people to a
because when the losses come they come
it's a wave that hit you so hard and you
lose from every direction you start
losing this direction and it's hitting
you north south east west and it's like
what the [ __ ] you just like you don't
know what to do so
you know you just start contemplating
all kind of stupid [ __ ] in your brain
because once your brain set itself on
uh giving up
like people you know with suicide once
it it gets in the brain
it's hard to fight it because once that
brain starts telling the body hey
you know this is what he keep
contemplating in his head and it make it
manifest
and that's why in the book man I hope
you know the message get to people I let
a guy read my the other book that's
complete that's that's just a fan not a
friend
and his text I can show you man he just
with crying faces he was like oh my God
bro this is amazing book man he was like
I never would have known you
been through this and you've been
through that oh my God you know so
that's what I try that's what I did in
the book man I didn't want everybody to
to glorify the streetness of me you know
like I had gang [ __ ] on the front
um all kind of [ __ ] man and I had it all
changed around because that ain't what I
want to glorify yeah and and people look
up to that and see like oh it's a cool
it's on covers book he's [ __ ] with it
it's a whole different message when it's
on the cover of your [ __ ] yeah yeah and
that ain't what I want to glorify I
don't want to glorify that man
that [ __ ] didn't get me nothing but but
hell brought to me don't get me wrong I
made I had a family because that's all
neighborhoods is Crips and bloods they
they come to be a family well when I was
banging it was like a family we trusted
each other and we can depend on each
other back in them days I haven't been
gang banging for man [ __ ] 20
something years
these gangbangers now man [ __ ] you can't
watch it he can't stand behind you like
you don't even want to get in a car with
him and get in the front seat and he in
the back seat because you just can't
trust him they smiling in your face and
they blow a bullet through the back of
your head just because they want your
girl or just because they want you you
got a brand new watch and a chain on and
you didn't put them up on it to get one
too and they'll kill you you know we so
easy to kill now we we run to this so
much I I had these back when I was I
feel like I'm talking about the Friday
movie right now
but also also
people are afraid to get punched in the
face now people are so afraid to [ __ ]
fight they'll shoot you first think
about the boxes they afraid too Floyd
don't get hit in the [ __ ] face Floyd
making sure he yeah no I'm talking about
fools will run to a gun so fast because
they're so afraid to get their ass I
know but I'm saying everybody nobody
wants to get hit in the face
we all got this selfie image face now
that we want to make sure we protect
because we we cameras are everywhere now
we live in this world that you have to
be camera ready all time all times if
you got a black eye busted nose a cut
knows a four or five teeth missing
you're not ready
so nobody wants to get hit no more
nobody wants to fight if you if you get
into an argument with a guy and you [ __ ]
him up because I'm a fighter and
everybody know this it's a fact if you
knew if you could find anybody that knew
me back when in my days I love to
[ __ ] fight I'm I'm something and oh I
never lost oh [ __ ] with a lot of ass
knocked a lot of people out but I come
up in an era where you can shake hands
after that
shot after you yeah because if I don't
do you bad one thing I never did was
false somebody knock them out and then
stomp them in the face while they are
and once you down you down the fight is
over you know I mean I kind of feel
[ __ ] up now yeah yeah
can't even do nothing about it yeah I
didn't I didn't uh you gotta remember
man I grew up in life
um
I never smoked cigarettes I never drink
the beer I never did any drugs I just
wasn't like a natural high kind of guy
so people was like why are you so
[ __ ] crazy
you don't do nothing do nothing it's
just natural you know what I'm saying
like I could sit up around people
drinking all day and just be like
be chilling as soon as I eat a piece of
a chicken sandwich and have a cup of
french fries I get [ __ ] itis
that's the that's what get me high I got
sleepy after I get food I know that
feeling you get it's like um a opiate
feeling it's straight up after you eat
good food you feel like that like man I
feel good because I used to be addicted
to
um pain pills man after I got shot in
the stomach well it started after I got
shot in the stomach and then a dentist
appointment right after
they pulled a tooth and they gave me
some
Vicodins whatnot then they gave me no
narcos wasn't out there needs they gave
me like a Tylenol 3 with codeine
that's what they had out back in the day
that that was the that was the the
narcos and the oxycontins and all that
[ __ ] it that wasn't even thought of back
in the day so I was popping the Tylenol
threes with codeine and like man
oh I feel good now
and after all the pain was gone me being
shot up and two things all that was gone
I was chasing that high now
so I used to go back to the dentist and
be like man this [ __ ] killing me
and it ain't even bothering me so they
can give me some Moon so I got addicted
and I was addicted for years to pain
pill I was addicted
from Tylenol three with codeines all the
way up to narcos to Vicodins to the real
pills said Vicodin on I was addicted to
those my wife used to get them because
she had surgery on her ankle I used to
take all of hers and I said go get more
go get more she would never take them
but I say go get some more go get some
because I was addicted yeah now I wasn't
addicted to the point where I hear
people saying they addicted and they
take
a handful of popping in my I will break
it one in half and take it early in the
day I just want to feel take my mind
away from because see I like I told you
bro I went through a lot of [ __ ] in my
life
and the first thing you does any human
nature would do is
try to find something to take that pain
away
drinking
smoking
popping pills heroin snorting you find
something to help take that pain away
because you feel like there's nothing
that you can do to take that pain away
from you so I was taking these pain
pills and I end up start taking one a
day to two a day and the most I went to
was three a day I was taking one in the
morning then around lunch time I just
get to thinking about stupid [ __ ] take
another one to eat and I'll just be like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] then dinner time then go
to bed
to the point I got addicted to them
three every day constantly yeah I'm
talking about for years bro to the point
one day me and my wife went to the movie
and I remember I started having stomach
problems
and they said it was called gerd acid
reflux so I was like [ __ ] going to the
hospital like what the [ __ ] do I got
stomach cancer or something wrong with
me because the [ __ ] was hurting check
this I want y'all to check it cause I'm
not afraid to know if something wrong
with me so check it they did the scan of
my whole body
you you're a pretty healthy dude you got
gerd they I never told them that I was
addicted to pills but I told them they
would say that's what it is it's eating
the lining of your stomach yeah those
pills [ __ ] you up yeah so so I just in
my brain just woke up one day I said I'm
not taking no [ __ ] more
and when I tell you bro
that [ __ ] eight seven eight days of
[ __ ] withdrawals move
I don't wish that [ __ ] on my worst enemy
I wanted to kill myself bro that's how
bad I felt I wanted to literally kill
myself I got a long text that I sent my
wife telling her that while she's at
work
like I can't take it no more because you
can't sleep you diarrhea your your mind
just a thousand places your body is
trying his best to force you to take
appeal because it's addicted to it so
it's making pains and frustration and
making the brain just go crazy but I
fought it out I just started reading the
Bible I just started just staying
focused and just trying to just sit up
and watch movies I try to go get some
sun it was just killing me but I
remember I was looking at YouTube
watching this young brother go through
it and every step of the way I was
watching them day one day two day three
day four everything he said he was going
through I was going through so he helped
me get through it good if I could see
this brother I would hug him I would
give him some [ __ ] money here bro
thank you for putting me through this
help walking with me through this phase
in my life right
so I remember he said on day seven day
eight
that
you wake up you don't know you finally
fall asleep because you don't get no
sleep when you're going through
withdrawals off of opiates man
you finally fall asleep and you you
sleep for eight hours ten hours and you
wake up and he said you're gonna have
these
these chill bumps all over your arm and
I I'm talking about exactly the wood he
said I had all these bumps I was like
what the [ __ ] and he was like you're
gonna see good you're gonna feel good
just a whole new you gonna be there and
that day finally had came
and I was like [ __ ] I'm back I'm normal
you know what I mean like what the [ __ ]
it was the best [ __ ] feeling in the
world bro I was like
where had this person been
just natural high bro yeah just being
natural and then I remember that day he
said you're gonna eat like a pig
and I was just eating me I'm talking
about eating fries all kind of [ __ ] and
I had a something with some chocolate in
it
and that feeling hit me that high
because they say in chocolate it has
that same thing yeah and I remember I
ate this chalk and I was like what the
[ __ ] did they put some of that [ __ ] in
there because I'm feeling this Good
Feeling Again
but it wasn't the drugs no more it was I
let all my acceptors whatever them
things they healed up and your body
naturally makes it if you get serotonin
and [ __ ] yeah if you get cut your body
insulates your brain instantly starts
sending that into that dopamine in your
body to make you feel better like you
know it just helps you
so I did all the research and that's why
I'm talking like this because I was
addicted to Appeals
years went by man I was happy as hell
like man I'm back I'm back me my wife
was happy we was a better place my mind
can think good
um I had caught the flu
and I was going through these body aches
and I found one of them [ __ ] pills
how long after about six years oh damn
God damn and I fail back off oh
but it only lasted for
six months
six months
and I said
not again
and this was just
Wachovia
oh no way so it was recent this was just
when Kobe first hit did you let people
know you're going through it again yeah
I I don't I don't have a problem with
saying hey man I was addicted to pain
pills because who's not everybody take
pain pills man that's it's the best
feeling in the [ __ ] world facts
so well I started letting my house know
just my wife and my daughter
and um
she was like you know let's go I'm with
you again let's go but the second goal
around was harder harder it was harder
ice had to go get in a hot tub just to
get a little relaxation bro just sit in
the hospital and lay down anybody aching
and hurt me just to let my eyes close
for my life until the water get cold
and then I'm like oh [ __ ] and I try to
turn the hot water back on to let the
touch because the heat was just letting
the body relax a little bit you know you
relax in the tub you [ __ ] fall asleep
I used to get out man and just go oh
nice and stare around the toilet on the
floor man throwing up and diary bro this
second time it took um
about 12 days
damn seven eight days of the hard [ __ ]
but then about three or four days for
your mind to get back
you you feel like man when is this [ __ ]
gonna get back like because I remembered
the first time after seven days I was
like yes yeah I was
[ __ ] something right and I and I went
back to this guy page and he said it was
called post something it was it's a name
for it it lasts a little longer the
second time so after about two weeks it
just I woke up one day I was like oh
[ __ ] there you go because you
recognizing when you if you've been
through it before you you know what
you're looking for and you're a fairly
sober person so you know your body well
yeah you wake up and feel like oh it's
gone yeah yeah and so
I did it again bro and I I I I as of
right now you know I've been clean now
two years good congrats man yeah man
it's a big thing dude
is it on your mind like that six years
where you're clean were you still
thinking about it every day and just
actively not doing it or did it go away
it went away you couldn't even bring
nothing like that around me I just it
just went away it's just like gone
so it's not like you're addicted to the
feeling as it's there it's not like
because you're saying you're fairly
sober I'm trying to get my head around
like you're addicted but at the same
time
you can just quit if you know you want
to well
now you just can't quit I'm saying from
what you're saying like one day I woke
up I'm done I just did it because I had
stomach pains if I never start getting
them stomach pains if I didn't start
eating or lining up in my stomach
[ __ ] my stomach up having these pains
that was just like the worst [ __ ] I
wouldn't have never stopped probably
would have probably kept taking them
because I was cool with it gotcha
because I wasn't overdoing it but I was
addicted
you know sometimes I only take like one
a day I would cut that up into three
small pieces I just wanted to get that
feeling a little bit of it if I can get
it you know what I'm saying look at you
but then you start you can't get them
from the doctor no more so now you
calling your homeboys and you calling up
people that could connect you with
people that can buy them for you or get
the prescription and they come bring
them to you and now you're paying a lot
of money because they start like I want
eight dollars appeal and you're trying
to buy 100 that's 800 and you would go
through that that hundred in about a
week and a half you feel what I'm saying
so now you looking at like God damn I'm
really a [ __ ] 15 two bands a month
just five pills yeah but then what
really made me kind of like
well well the stomach stuff made me quit
the first time the second time like I
said after about five or six months
what made me quit because fentanyl they
start making fake pills and I said you
know what I lost two people that was
real close to me to taking pills opiates
and they died
so I said you know what
I gotta quit
and I just told her I remember it was
black lives matter all on TV and all
that stuff and the Kobe going and I said
I gotta I gotta quit and she didn't know
because I was keeping it from her she
was like you back on it oh my God
come on now let's well let's go and I
just said I can't do it no more because
I lost a couple people see it was things
that was happening made me say
I quit now
I look at it like you have to be a
strong person and just see something and
say I don't want to do it no more yeah I
Pat myself on the back Dr Drew was
astonished by him that's how he was with
cocaine Dr Drew's like that doesn't ever
happen but yeah that seemed with me
leave it I'ma [ __ ] die from this [ __ ]
I gotta I just stopped that to have done
it yet since I knew it like this is only
going to bring bad [ __ ] it's only gonna
be bad I'm gonna [ __ ] die from using
this it's gonna get worse and then how
many people are depending on my ass I
gotta stop right now it's gonna get
worse bro it ain't nowhere you can go
but to the worst points in your in your
life and it's very expensive yeah and
you get there faster like like the
people that drink that lean that [ __ ] is
expensive I had no idea I was in Vegas
and a couple of my friends drinking but
they're rich I'm like how much are those
bottles they're like 39 four like four
thousand four bands per bottle
just like it's nothing they going
through pouring it and [ __ ] sodas and
well if you got money do your thing but
some people don't got money and this
lien started a whole new wave of these
[ __ ] Jacker kids and these home
robberies because they are [ __ ]
addicted to opiates and they're gonna
shoot you because they need that [ __ ]
they gotta have it just because they're
on Instagram with like nice clothes
doesn't mean they're not junkies yeah
not everybody but some of these boys
some of these other streets you just
don't see it you don't you don't see
what they did that day to get that ball
to post that day yeah you know you know
they doing interviews and they they
celebrities and they sitting up and they
yeah yeah you know what I'm saying yeah
I got a show next week but but in the
back of their head they can't wait to
get this [ __ ] interview over so they
can go today addiction
some of them sit there with their Cup in
their hand it's sad they Double Cup it
became cool it became like the blunt
yeah oh you got a blunt like oh you got
a cup you don't gotta cut your own drink
you don't sip this [ __ ] yeah it became
because the well the radio I'm how you
Future's literally saying big Pharma in
the beginning of his [ __ ] song yes
it's a big farm like yo people are not
in their head the big Pharma right now
that's crazy to me I [ __ ] a future also
what the [ __ ] are you doing man big
Pharma fools on the school bus are
saying big Pharma right the [ __ ] it's
some crazy [ __ ] you're joking no I'm not
I'm not kidding yeah but but but y'all
show is the first show that I uh
announced that I was addicted to drugs
damn really you never talked about this
never talked about it because it's my
personal business
I feel like
people need to hear it and when they
hear it coming from Dave Franklin yeah
a lot of people because there's a lot of
people that's taking pills right now I
mean you just saw a random dude on
YouTube and felt inspired like I'm gonna
do this [ __ ] with you and they someone
they [ __ ] love like yo I'm on pills
this Fool's going through this [ __ ] so
I'm playing asking I gotta get off this
[ __ ] if I was smart
well don't stay smart because I think
I'm smart but if I was on it and sharp
and was thinking I should have had
documented me going through everything I
should have talked to the camera let
them see the pain in me here you are
right now though like at least you're
getting it off your chest you know yeah
yeah but but still I see what you said I
couldn't put it on a YouTube channel and
people could have went there and went
with me day for day for day for day even
my second go-around day for day for day
for day and somebody uh gets something
out of that by looking they will too
late you're gonna change at least one
person's life for the better yeah and
that's all that matters if it's one
person that's like yo in 30 years you
got me off pills but that's a big
[ __ ] thing yeah like like this last
Kobe stint that remember I don't know if
you saw the picture with me I mean I was
talking to you and then I saw the post
I'm like yo what though yeah yeah I had
caught you know I fought Kobe for man
didn't get it for two years man I was
like damn I'm I'm one of the ones that
just won't get it you know so it hit me
I remember telling my wife I said I
don't feel cool some just don't feel why
I had this itch in my throat and I was
like son just don't feel right so I said
let me test myself so I tested it with
the tester at home and it showed a light
second
um line line so I said I showed her she
said
I said no
I waited like an hour later and did it
again
it was darker I said hey and MOHAI crazy
like
get out of here she put a mask on going
there so I said okay man I said I got
covered so that night
was really like the worst night it was
like I had chills body aches
um
it was just that I was still eating
normal everything second day I was cool
I feel like I was like damn I beat it in
one day that's how I felt
that third day started raining
and I said
damn man something just don't feel right
so I felt like I had to throw up
so I got up out of the bed and I started
walking to the bathroom and that's all I
remember I passed out what the [ __ ] my
wife said it sounded like somebody
pushed the refrigerator over she came
running in there screaming I'm calling
9-1-1 oh my God oh my God she said my
eyes were just rolled up in my head
so I go to the hospital
they do a a CT scan MRI my head and all
that stuff
and they say they see a blood clot on
the brain
so I'm like what the [ __ ] so my family
just everybody depressed like [ __ ] so
they like we're gonna give you these
blood thinners for a few days then we're
gonna send you home
and you're gonna have to administer
these blood thinners
for two months on your own now these
[ __ ] they was coming in here
shooting a needle in my stomach shooting
this [ __ ] felt like acid every five
hours six hours
I was like oh my God so I remember the
second day in the hospital
third day in the hospital
they uh
they came in they said you're gonna have
to do it yourself because you've got to
start prepping yourself to do it so I
had to grab my stomach they said don't
go straight in go at a slant so I went
out of slant and push push push push
push push and he keep pushing to the the
needle retract they go pop
so I did it
this is going to be my life man a shot
earned like a little short nah it was a
needle shot full of some [ __ ] though you
still haven't do that right then the
blood no I'm gonna tell you to thin the
blood so it can thin the clot out that
they so-called said I had so a black
doctor came in there her name was Dr
Shaw she said I got some good news for
you
and I said what is that she said you
ain't never had a blood clot I said what
y'all been shooting this [ __ ] in me for
three days the [ __ ] are you talking
about I just
you can still see the mark from the IV
pull that [ __ ] blood was just jump shoot
I said get the [ __ ] off of me and call
my wife I said babe I don't got no blood
clot she was like what
oh my God thank you Lord thank you thank
you thank God I said man come get me
she came and got me they they
wheelchaired me down let me go home
um I still was dealing dealing with the
Kobe [ __ ] anybody had Kobe you have this
laziness for like two three days it's
just like you just feel like you just
sucks yeah so I did that and um
I was a hundred percent like two days
after I took myself home
and I was like [ __ ] I'm back jumped in
the car got some sun and I was on the
freeway drove down to the city rolled
around came back I was like I feel good
so
I'm here now but that's what put me in
the hospital not the covet the covert I
could have fought at home well I thought
you had like super bad Kobe and that's
why I'm like I even text him like yo
what the [ __ ] cause I just talked to you
yeah so what happened what caused you to
pass out like that well I had took this
medicine that's supposed to
help
uh fight bacteria viruses and all that
[ __ ] A friend of mine said man this [ __ ]
is the [ __ ] is third world country [ __ ]
blah blah blah I took it it was like a
paste on a spoon just a little bit of
[ __ ] swallowed it drink some water
for some odd reason that [ __ ] made me
want to throw up
but I I don't know what made me pass out
to this day I just don't know but I know
that [ __ ] made me want to throw up I got
up so I blamed that that [ __ ] I took on
me passing out also and I cussed him out
[ __ ] you I'll kill you and I was
like I really was on some murder [ __ ]
because I could have lost my life I
could have never came back yeah after I
passed out you know what I'm saying I
don't know what would my wife said if
you would have saw you she said I
thought you were dead and you hit I hit
my head my arm was off you see the
scratches and [ __ ] scar yeah damn just
damn so
um that's what made me pass out I think
we don't know what did the doctor's
excuse for saying sorry we [ __ ] up on
your brain skin my attorneys deal with
that oh all right all right you
misdiagnosed me yeah that's some serious
[ __ ] stressful man and you pumping [ __ ]
at me that my body shouldn't need while
you're sick you thin in my blood you
know come on man no well we gonna miss
diet we gonna misdiagnose y'all bank
account a little bit how about that yeah
I feel you I totally I'd be in the same
position of just so pissed I couldn't
even think about that yeah I would rip
my [ __ ] out to and left because what if
they would have said hey it's a it's a
blood clot so bad that we have to go do
brain surgeon get in there and fix it
y'all cut my [ __ ] head open skull
wide open all up in there and got in
there talking it wasn't a blood clot
come on man you don't get some super
malpractice [ __ ] right there yeah you
don't do that and this is like a big
place you know Kaiser Permanente so it's
like oh I see the [ __ ] oh come on man
I'm gonna grease it up
well not even like yo they're making me
pump myself full of [ __ ] and then they
go no you're fine I'm [ __ ] suing
right after I pumped it the doctor
I like I just shot this [ __ ] in me yeah
what's up guys take another moment to
talk one of our long time sponsors this
is on it right now onit.com
onnit.com forward slash Yola that gets
you 10 off of everything on the site
except for the weights let's get right
into it if you're a fan already you know
what's going on Anna is the peak human
optimization this is for mental and
physical well-being if one of your goals
is to get super buff on it can help you
out with that if one of your goals to
have mental Clarity gut health they also
have things for that it does have
something to do with how you feel and
how you feel is everything do you wake
up right me do you wake up super foggy
and really not ready to go Alpha Brain
is a daily vitamin you take it it's
cognitive focus it helps you just get
mental Clarity and not like not being
tired just being alert you remember
those days we get eight breakfast before
school you got there a little early your
pencil was sharp and you started school
you felt awesome that's the feeling it
gives me I feel like all right I'm
prepared today remember guys audit.com
forward slash Yola or if you're on
Spotify Apple doesn't matter if you're
on YouTube go below you'll see the blue
link right there click the on link it
already has our code linked up to it
just go ahead and pick your stuff
what's up guys just taking a moment to
talk about one of our sponsors this is
betterhelp this is a service that
connects you with licensed therapist
real quick this is not a crisis hotline
that's not what this is this is therapy
session after session building blocks
helping you achieve what you think you
can personally when I was in Oregon I
had no homies I had nobody I was the new
kid there I was the poorest kid there
and one of the few brown ones so when I
was there I was just sitting there going
through it it was not fun I had no one
to talk to it was terrible I didn't have
access to something like better help
like that it didn't this didn't exist
back then but if I did 10th grade would
have been a lot easier please don't be
embarrassed mental health and physical
health are just as equally as important
sometimes it could just be stress you
were completely stressed out maybe
you're a new call or a new job you just
had a a child your new mom new sometimes
we all need to talk to somebody not
whether you're eight years old or 80. so
right now if you go to betterhelp.com
forward slash dope you get 10 off your
first month they match you up with these
therapists who's going to actually work
is this okay adhesive this is
confidential guys this is convenient you
can do it from your own room once again
guys thank you for supporting the brands
that support us back to the episode
this month that book's coming out this
month let's say that right where can
everybody find it at you're gonna be
able to get it everywhere Amazon I got
deals with everybody Amazon I also got
an audio version for the people that
love Franklin they get to hear the voice
thank you got that
um I got a uh ebook
uh this and I got a heart a hard back uh
the hard copy with the hard [ __ ] on
there and that graphic novels the
graphic novel man this by itself oh man
[ __ ] cool man whoever Drew this [ __ ]
great job great job this is tight that's
gonna kill bro this is super tight
um
real quick I just I mean I won't get
into every single thing detail wise but
I just wanted to let the first time I
ever met you I know maybe we met
downtown I don't know if you thought it
was as hilarious as I thought yeah I
went to meet you I'm like I know what he
looks like I don't know what car he's in
I have no idea what's going on I won't
say exactly what I was doing but
I called you like yo where are you at
yeah and I know you play the voice but
for me
when I get on the [ __ ] phone I'm in
an alley and you know yo I'm across the
street in a charger I go [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] right I'm waiting my whole life
to be on a mission here we [ __ ] go
and that's the first time I ever met you
I'm walking down the alley I'm like he
really isn't a charge huh
all right this is blowing my [ __ ]
mind man
it was too much for me like all right
it's my whole life
yeah that's how we met I still got that
headshot oh for real hell yeah I still
got that headshot of course I do
um so
uh working do you have a website or
anything yeah man it's it's called solo
Game Changer solo gamechanger.com Game
Changer are you a big gamer
I wish I was because everybody like man
you need to be you need to be on Twitch
you know you would [ __ ] cry I don't
know if you know how much money you can
make on that but I just don't know how
to set that up man y'all know the rapper
dude name um uh MERS
yo my me and my fiance our first date
ever was a murder show for real yes MERS
is one of my favorite rappers of all
[ __ ] time I saw him when he went to
Strange Music and then came back and
Living Legends just aren't pumping out
no music right now I just brought it up
like yo where's the Living Legends at I
know merge is still out here so man
that's my God no [ __ ] that's my
favorite artists of all time I don't I
can't believe you just said that is he
on the CD twitch
I don't know or see like were you saying
he was trying to hook me up with twitch
y'all we got to get you on there and he
was saying man you can eat man and I'll
make 100K huh
I just need to get what the team that
could do it that's what I'm doing this
week actually I'm buying the PC because
I got a big twitch I don't use this [ __ ]
yeah dude you would crush it on there
yeah I mean there's a kid making 400
bands off of GTA role play right now on
Twitch what a month a GTA role play oh
no man you are the role
you were crushing the foreign
a year I'm with it just to play games
twice a month twice a week yeah [ __ ] it
and you play your own character come on
man yeah
and talking
you can have people losing their [ __ ]
just to sign up for the thing I mean you
you could be twitch
we're gonna get to that after yeah
there's hundreds of comments coming in
right now [ __ ] everybody like I
signed up right now I'd sub right now I
already know it you start off with 30k a
[ __ ] month the day you start yeah
twitch is serious they let they and they
let so much [ __ ] happen it's
it's cool for me I smoke so much so you
know like I always get demonetized and
[ __ ] so twitch is they loud it's like a
420 section they [ __ ] with them man
they're [ __ ] heavy yeah okay um so
solo gamechanger.com solo
gamechanger.com is where you're gonna be
able to order the book
um everything at the merchandise the
shirts the hats everything I love that
Rockstar lets you do your [ __ ] thing
as you because a lot of companies
wouldn't do that yeah and the good thing
about Rockstar is man my relationship
with them this is key they gonna they
gonna get behind it good Mark it in you
know helping me push it they're gonna
put it on my platforms man I'll tell you
I love Rockstar man yeah what you were
telling me earlier Mike I'd love this
[ __ ] out of them too they sound cool as
[ __ ] what's right there man they they
treat your boy right man I have nothing
negative or wrong to say bro and not
just because they brought me back to do
the contract man you know with Dre and
them and stuff but some of the online
yeah the online deals and stuff
um it's just they always just been cool
you know what I'm saying I can you know
ask them for any advice you know when I
need them they always right there they
they never was this far away even though
they are far away
um they still take phone calls you know
what I'm saying I'm talking about
the the tops they take phone calls from
me you know what I'm saying so but I'm
I'm a rock star team member man forever
man you know whatever they need me to do
I'm I'm I'm here man you know they put
out some big news this [ __ ] week
right yes oh yeah oh yeah they did they
did people they did not me yeah it's on
Worldstar I was on live about a week ago
and somebody brought because we brought
you up and I've talked a little bit
about how I met you and then you know I
was talking to Donnie and and poo at
that dinner and they were talking about
GTA go yeah if you ever want to just you
know put me in this Mission just make me
a drug dealer that's fine I'll Lead You
In the grow room and Donny's like
it's not a bad idea so I've been sitting
here for six years waiting for this call
like man maybe one day it'll [ __ ]
happen there's gonna be Grow rooms like
you know a little fat kid just like
bring you into the grow room and never
see me again that's all I care because
we talked about it
you're immortalized forever did you see
me in the grow room
DJ poo movie to grow around I didn't see
the girl he told me grow house he was uh
filming on the black magic he was just
preaching to me about how he's gonna
start using the Black Magic Camera for
that for that movie yeah that's uh
there's a the what's his name the
smaller little Duvall right he's in that
yeah yeah no I haven't seen that one I
haven't seen that one yeah I'm in there
man I'm in that movie too that's what I
forgot to say yeah he he grow house he
cast me in the grow house man you tell
me about that anything DJ Pooh does man
I don't give a [ __ ] what it is man he's
gonna call me and give me a shot it's up
to me it's up to me to want to do it
that's how our relationship is now I
don't have to probably go read that much
or once he casts me I'm cast now yeah
because I'd improve myself with it
exactly you don't need to go like you
got to teach him is he gonna need to be
like sheltered yeah no he's you know
what the [ __ ] we're talking about that's
right and then the good thing about it
is with him he gonna make sure that he
write me a role when he go in the
writing movie when he writing it he
already writing it for me so he gonna
let me be me so it's not going to be
hard for me to act because you can't say
hey solo I want you to be a doctor
I'm not an actor not an actor yeah you
can I probably you're not there you're a
little coaching yeah yeah I definitely
probably could you know what I'm saying
with somebody coaching me to do it I I'm
damn sure gonna try
um but he give me
I I want to say the stereotypical roles
like you know Solo or hood [ __ ] so I'm
gonna write him some hood [ __ ] but if he
writing about a hood dude I would rather
me be the guy that can play that [ __ ]
for real yeah I love to be on the screen
you feel what I'm saying so I'm like I
say I'm very thankful for him man that
he keeps me
at the front of his brain when he
writing [ __ ] you know what I'm saying
the Franklin character man I I owe DJ
Pooh all of this that y'all see man like
I said y'all hear me talking man I just
can't stop giving my dude his praise man
cause I wouldn't even be sitting in this
seat without him bro trust me well I
mean it's great bro like we were talking
about earlier you're [ __ ] forever
immortalized yeah you're right next to
Sonic and Super Mario Bros
if you think about it I mean I mean for
real though I know you don't see it like
that well GTA is GTA is the best game of
all time yeah of all time one of the
best things in entertainment and I've
never changed my [ __ ] character
because you have the special you can
slow drive and I'm like I'll be frankly
for [ __ ] 10 years I have never
changed characters
yeah it is real awkward when you're like
playing with your kid you wake up you're
Franklin he walks over grabs the bong
and [ __ ] hit the wrong [ __ ] I'll
always hit the ball and that's it
me and DJ Pooh how I got to roll
that's the whole [ __ ] bro that's why I'm
saying this [ __ ] gonna be crazy bro I
got a question how long does it take to
record the vocals for GTA that [ __ ] took
well you gotta remember it's not vocal
see what y'all what y'all what y'all be
getting um well a lot of people get
mixed up with when you are a voice actor
for a video game you are also a
performer everything you see Franklin
Doug in the game I had to do it all that
running they put you in one of the songs
the fighting the breaking the window so
you really sock fools why this [ __ ] like
that
all that all them cut scenes that you
see us doing when we really playing the
game and it's stopped and you walk into
the room and like so what's up y'all so
what we doing we have to act all of that
out me Michael Trevor uh Lester all of
us are in the suits with cameras I did
not know that ever really and we really
had to act all of that [ __ ] out bro no
we ain't just so much fun reading
nothing that's what I thought that's
right yeah [ __ ] get on the ground get
on the ground yeah
so that's why they put the motorcycle in
GTA for you that's my real motorcycle
yeah bro I came up the street just like
that on my Harley day oh my God so like
I said my story is so I can't wait for
this [ __ ] book
I've read a book in a long time I'm very
excited now all right let me show you
something real quick real quick real
quick man hey man I just think it's
funny it's like the charger the
motorcycle like it's too much it's so
crazy he's got attention to details so
[ __ ] on point it's crazy okay when
it's in the other part but the motion
caption man the motion caption [ __ ] is
is what took so long it took for me to
film
um GTA 5 for us to film it uh three and
a half years
whoa took about three
that's crazy it took about three years
because you gotta do the whole dialogue
the story yeah because you guys are
really doing that just capturing your
voices and tons and tons and tons of
script man when I tell you tons and tons
and tons that I gotta study and rehearse
and I'm doing it in New York so I'm
leave here and go to New York for three
weeks and I'm there for three weeks
do all our filming and whatever we do
and we're doing then come back home for
like three weeks and then back to New
York for three weeks so I was doing that
for like two to three years wow back and
forth so I was by coastal living you
feel me
um dope as [ __ ] though man yeah but when
you see when y'all see Franklin man
cameras when y'all see Franklin doing
anything he's doing in there it's either
me doing it live or a stunt man doing it
like when Franklin had to jump from the
back of the car to the boat yeah yeah
like one of the openings yeah stunt man
had to because I [ __ ] they really had
it set up in the studio just like that
and you have to [ __ ] really jump up
there I had so much more respect for
[ __ ] the video game right now I did
not know you guys were doing that [ __ ]
yeah you have to really do that [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] I thought it was just some
oh yeah what's up in my mind it's just
magic some dude back there yeah
I wish that's how it's so realistic
that's why it's so realistic look look
quick story man when when I went to and
it's in here when I went to um go do the
Rockstar [ __ ] I wanted to quit two times
on set because you gotta remember we
didn't know we were doing Grand Theft
Auto to like after about two years of
being on set about a year and a half
you're just making the paradise we
making so-called Paradise they're that
exclusive with that game they couldn't
have it they're talking about the lead
what are the leads
that you were in the kitchen set but
Rockstar moves in silence man one thing
about them they are so secret and they
that's the most secretive should I ever
heard they are they smart when I worked
with them man I just the director man oh
my God he's he's he's the best it's a
couple of directors there but that one
the one director he don't like his name
being out there so I won't put it out
there but he is the best
he's the [ __ ] best you guys are
making a movie by the way it's a video
game it's a video oh if they did a movie
I'm saying that's how you guys are
filming it you're filming a movie
hey if they if anybody did a Grand Theft
Auto movie please cast me because you
know sometimes they say oh we gonna get
uh
what's the dude to play killmonger
um
what's his name Black Panther
Michael B Jordan yeah Jordan to play uh
to play Franklin oh you know no man
please come back again I got you I'll
get in shape I'll do push-ups I'll do
all that [ __ ] now you be a real actor
like for real man if they do a movie oh
Bobby but that just that just goes to
show you that
they don't need to do a movie that's how
big the game biggest game of all time
they don't need to I punch somebody in
the sixth grade or fifth grade with my
uncle I've been hooked ever since since
part three I punched a lady right by the
pier and went
the focus is way better than Shinobi and
[ __ ] and I was hooked since the fifth
grade man so yeah man yeah I thought bro
thank you for being here this this is so
fun I just don't know the fans gonna
love this [ __ ] so much man I hope they
do man I appreciate it you're still I
can't wait to read this [ __ ] book
yeah like I said I'm gonna have you I'm
gonna help y'all some copies man in like
two days they'll be here in two days I
got like 50 books I'm gonna have to get
them out to all of them let us know and
if it is in two days we'll take we'll
throw like overlay it on the screen if
the actual done cover yeah because this
doesn't come out till Monday okay so we
have a couple days to edit and [ __ ] like
that yeah yeah we'll put the links in
the description yeah we'll put the links
and all that [ __ ] just whatever you need
will help you I mean I know I am excited
as [ __ ] to read that just that little
thing I didn't know it was like part
animated too yeah there's some animation
in there it's sick man I like that yeah
like like that right there I can leave
you that you can keep that you can read
through appreciate that's the first
chapter in the book I want you to read
that but this right here I can't because
that's the that's the first one yeah is
this is this is bro you have a whole
nother thing on your hands here yeah I
went a whole nother directions
the writer with me Yousef
um that's he come up with the number
that idea right there man with the comic
does so smart so [ __ ] smart put this
in every [ __ ] Game Stop in America oh
man oh God damn out of here gone I mean
you have such a a strong cult following
that so you can do whatever you want
yeah as long as it's real authentic it's
[ __ ] sold do you think most Gamers
realize that you guys are real people
I don't think a lot too
um they they they do what they don't
like like look at my followers on
Instagram man
um me Ned and Stephen well Stephen
Fowler is he's about a million now
because he's walking dead he played
Trevor he's in Walking Dead he's in
Better uh saw he's in snow Pier so he
took the he took the the Trevor Road and
ran expanded the ship he went and got
roles in movies and [ __ ] me he was so
good to the house and said [ __ ] this
stupid [ __ ] I'm not an actor that's just
every everybody will tell you that I'd
be like man they like get head shots go
and start doing stuff man [ __ ] I don't
want to do all that [ __ ] man [ __ ] that
you could though if you wanted to man
slink he ran with the black Jesus and
other stuff yeah Black Jesus you ever
seen Black Jesus show no
well I'll show you later yeah but uh
Michael you know they took their stuff
and rolled with it man he plays Michael
I never never seen it Luke he plays
Michael man but they um
I think that if everybody knew who we
was we should we should have 10 20
million followers easy easy because
Rockstar has about a hundred and
something easy as [ __ ] man I mean people
want to connect with the person they've
[ __ ] been chilling with every day for
years yeah and like no my favorite
characters are a real person yeah
where's the book like it's easy like
give me the book I'm telling you bro I
was just we were just out eating
yesterday and I get this all the time no
matter where I go Vegas out of state
anywhere and a guy just recognized my
voice and I've seen him just was looking
and I was like and I said what's up man
he was like do you um
play the character uh Franklin and are
you Frank and I like Yay like oh [ __ ]
and and he's he works in the restaurant
just from the sound loud can I get
pictures what's your Instagram see that
lets you know that they don't know
nobody know
it's like there's millions of people
that's like where is he millions of
people I bet there's pressure on you're
about to [ __ ] go on oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah bro so you know we are
supposed to have millions and millions
of followers but me I'm so
down to earth dude man I don't give a
damn man if I had 50 followers if I had
5 000 fathers I'm still gonna be me you
can't take Franklin from me I'm still
the guy that laid the voice and the
performance to Franklin that's even
crazier than me bro I didn't know that
that's why I say we are performers if
you look at my old TMZ's man I got two
TMZ's out where they done popped up in
my face and I tell them man we
performance man we're performers on
another level because you got to
remember I did movies and I did this
[ __ ] right
movies you dressed fully costume you're
sitting in a real car you sitting at a
real desk you're doing on real [ __ ] you
got a real [ __ ] pretty good close to
real gun in your hand
it's easy to fall into character on here
you got a [ __ ] scuba diving suit on
with all these [ __ ] balls all over
you a helmet on camera in your face
wires hanging all kind of [ __ ] and you
you gotta act out all of that [ __ ] you
see Franklin and everybody doing we
acting that [ __ ] out but we also acting
it out with
a [ __ ] a wooden box and a crate and a
a pole coming from right here with a a
little fake steering wheel in your car
so you gotta imagine we gotta go into
and imagine you are an actor I don't
know if you know that that is straight
act I am I'm a performer too because I'm
performing now because I closed my eyes
and they say this is the ocean out this
way they already see it on the computer
like this is what we're gonna put the
ocean at you sit looking out the water
and you're looking at a wall and you're
like that's the ocean so you gotta
pretty much just like
all right that's the ocean like damn
look at the water grab a rock well a
Broadway actor yeah that's literally
what's going on here man yeah bro so do
you ever think you'd be doing that no
you notice the head from everything you
told me in the beginning to be like yo
Super Mario Sonic you know Franklin
Trevor and Michael I never in my wildest
dreams would have thought I would have
been doing any of this let alone a book
um
just being in this world man because of
how I came up a [ __ ] up well not a [ __ ]
up because what's a [ __ ] up in the in
the in the minds of the government and
them they say anything we do is illegal
if you [ __ ] up in your own mind then
you're a [ __ ] once you say yourself
like I am a [ __ ] yeah then that's
when you hit yeah I classify myself as a
survivalist because I come up in poverty
and I didn't have [ __ ] and all I and I
knew it was a better world out there and
the only way I can get to it was to
gravitate to
so-called illegal drugs you feel what
I'm saying because everything that's
illegal is it's a [ __ ] sitting
up in a room that makes it illegal but
it's legal to them with like you said
future big Pharma you feel what I'm
saying it's legal from then if they
could tax you it should sleep because if
you look at pills that nothing but
heroin that's it straight up so I can
say I was a heron addict for all these
years because it's opiate that's what
they do they get it in a b
scratching I used to be scratching bro
and then when you addicted to anything
your stomach tells you your stomach gets
hurting I need more of that [ __ ] you'd
be like [ __ ] I gotta I gotta get another
how to pop another pill your stomach get
to tripping when I talk to my boys that
be on lean they said the same [ __ ] they
say man your stomach hurts bad with lean
yeah so they got hair up and get some
lean in them they gotta hurry up because
the body is saying hey I'm gonna start
tripping on your ass
so yeah man
I came a long way I come a long way man
and I and I got a ways to go man I know
I still this book is just only up to
Grand Theft Auto I'm still living my
life man I'm still raising the family
I'm still being a provider and a
protector yeah how long you been with
your wife
we've been married 25 years
wow 25 congrats on that that's big been
together 30 years man being able to
tolerate and be [ __ ] friends with
somebody that long is Big that's big
yeah bro been with that lady a long time
man congrats man yeah
um
so all right before we get here solo
gamechanger.com guys go check that [ __ ]
out Marty got anything else thank you
man we really appreciate it
appreciate appreciate it one thing
though before we go we didn't talk about
I want to talk about it man what the
contract man
see y'all y'all know what the hell going
on when I say the contract you know no
y'all don't know what's up hey y'all
tripping I said he even came here oh no
I said it made y'all do y'all [ __ ]
due diligence before I came here man the
fans is really gonna kick y'all it's
okay they know I don't play I don't know
the games as much no more [ __ ] that you
supposed to do your due diligence I
don't know what the contract is I'm
gonna show you what the contract is man
you ripping oh man this is [ __ ] that
okay it came out December 15th
oh yeah no I have the same [ __ ] game
and I play it I don't play I never
played online before bro I just can't I
don't understand this [ __ ] bro yeah I've
never played online or nothing I'm gonna
show you bro I still got the same Grand
Theft Auto I just top of the top of the
mountain with your [ __ ] character
you tripping bro
who is that oh I've seen this [ __ ] it
was on [ __ ] uh it was on the New York
on the thing on my page Town Square I
mean uh times Max yeah Time Square is
yeah so oh see that's what it's called
the contract the contract oh I didn't
know what it was called it's like the
new it's like the store a new storyline
correct but it's Dr Dre's in it like
like like look
um let me show you I didn't know what's
called the contract I don't I'm not
gonna act like I know anything about it
I should know about this show yeah all
right now all my homies are on the road
on that GTA role play right now you know
what I'm saying I just saw it I just
don't get it like
Franklin Clinton dog
what
[Music]
Anderson packed
they gave you a beard and [ __ ]
that was my car right there the money I
mean yeah the Monte Carlo
Anderson Park
yeah
excuse my ignorance here so this is like
a new variation came out December 15th
oh all new missions and everything
that's where my brothers
my little brother's like I've been
playing the new GT I'm like the new GTA
is not out yet for what are you talking
about Franklin is a boss he has a beard
he's gonna run the whole [ __ ] in this
Corporation it's called Franklin Clinton
man and partners I run up I run a whole
new operation now Franklin is filthy
rich Dr Dre loses his music somebody
steals his music and all the players to
get come help get Dr Dre music back they
have to come see me first and I'll send
you where to go oh my gosh did you get a
mission caller now and I go on missions
shoot [ __ ] up all that [ __ ] man see I'm
out online dude
to say my same console over like you
said with twitch I don't understand how
to do online yeah I don't even know how
to log in to play GTA so I've been back
to work that's what I've been back to
work how long you been working on that
that's it uh it took me a couple months
to film all of that it's not even faster
like a prequel to GTA six it's
completely like a little bonus package
it's just some extra online because you
know uh people didn't think they see
Franklin and Lamar back man but we came
back with Dr Dre DJ Pooh in it all of
that [ __ ] crazy yeah DJ yeah I'm missing
out bro I'm over here y'all gotta Google
it go check it out no I I knew there was
another thing I just didn't know it was
called the contract but I don't play
online oh man you gotta go on there DJ
poo on there DJ Poo's a character I just
go to the IV Jimmy Jimmy and RV yeah
scope he's in it
what I do
is that your [ __ ] house
oh it's a golf course oh my God
you gotta go check it out bro
yo
man this shit's so cool though are you
getting text messages on the game
as you're the oh my God
get me out of me next time
oh listen studios are supposed to be in
Studio City
finally got put himself finally put
himself in the game oh man you gotta see
it when we hit the studio on Lamar
grabbed a mic and start rapping in Dre's
studio and if they put on the beat cutie
pie and he getting that [ __ ]
riding around with chop he started
rapping like a [ __ ] bro I gotta
get online I gotta get online
I can't be on here if I ain't talking
about the contract man the contract
y'all so that's out right now yeah
December since December 13th December
15th um it got released yeah I saw your
post like my dad's a big [ __ ] ad
right there that's for my brother man my
little brother's like I want the new
Grand Theft Auto I'm like the new you
know you're late my Verizon came out a
long time ago I'm talking about Grand
Theft Auto 5. I'm so late do we just
work I don't play games with Dr Dre
um DJ Pooh Anderson pack um he got all
of the music on there Dre just dropped
all the music with him Nipsey uh Eminem
[Music]
you name it everybody on he drops songs
in the in the video game in our new game
called the Cubs I mean you were in the
studio as a mission and they're making
music this was [ __ ] crazy yeah man
that's pretty cool [ __ ] all right I got
you got it Google I'll get online get on
your phone and go into YouTube man this
will help you out a lot
um just going in put in uh the contract
uh cut scenes just watch it on scenes
and you can watch all this [ __ ] with me
so I just gotta download the pack right
for for my online [ __ ] to play it's free
you just download it going in down all
right the contract I'm slipping we were
thinking about putting a little gaming
station right here too yeah we need to
do it because I don't use it I don't use
it that's what you said I actually had
something sitting behind there where the
game is playing right now
up there
so you gotta I gotta ask you before you
got here damn set designer yeah so I
have to I have to man that's part of the
Rockstar team GTA contracts the contract
man if you ain't downloaded it go
download it which I know everybody
around the world and downloaded have
been playing it man just go and play it
and continue to play it I know everybody
probably finished it already because you
walk up in the office with me you know
and I and and I pull you in as my
partner if you create your character now
we Partners in the business to go help
Dre get his [ __ ] back but we also
helping a whole lot of rich people fix
their problems too so I'm like a fixer
now I run a company I'm filthy rich
being um Tanisha got married in the game
we had kids like I'm [ __ ] sequel to a
movie over here man this is tight kids
and everything man yeah oh [ __ ] all
right I'm slipping I got your weed in
there called LD Organics [ __ ]
getting high we we start our own weed
brand in the game gotta go play it bro
all right
it had an accident in the smokers
everywhere and everybody was coming out
to come check the accident and they were
high as a [ __ ] LD Organics man
okay all right Davis I got you I will
download that [ __ ] today I got the PS5
I use that [ __ ] yeah I'll be back too
and I'm gonna quiz you on it I got you
back man I got you my little brother's
gonna be blast with me right now when
you watch this show my little brother
lives on GTA so I'll get it I'll I'll
get it today yeah yeah I could not leave
without saying that man I thought you
was going to ask me about it but I see
you slipping I'm [ __ ] up apparently
and then again people are gonna get
pissed like I told you should have been
gaming they tell me every day why don't
you came on Twitch and you know what
this does for me and this is for anybody
that's watching um right now
um you have to do your due diligence on
his latest [ __ ] because
you want you want to you want you don't
want to not interview somebody and then
not bring up their latest stuff and
that's why Rockstar be saying make sure
nah they no they don't do that they just
say who who you going to do it I stepped
out of doing what I supposed to do for
you only for you appreciate it um
Rockstar said like they want me to say
hey I'm gonna go do this interview with
my man yelling them over here
they want to contact you to find out
what you know before I even do it and
they're honors I stepped out of the
because I came and do my own thing today
like other people they gotta go through
Rockstar to even set an interview up
with them because Rockstar want to make
sure you asking the right questions damn
they got their product [ __ ] yeah so
that's why I we have to not just talk
about this this is good this is a good
Pub but you I have to talk about the
contract with Dr Dre and us man that
just came out December 15th well look
you might have just got me back on
[ __ ] playing games man so all right
all right there it is all right and then
after this we'll figure out your Twitch
[ __ ]
I'll [ __ ] stream twitch on the
contract all right make up for this all
right and make sure y'all run the
trailer
did you run the trailer oh can we The
Contract Trailer yeah hell yeah it's
free it's on YouTube okay I mean because
we get [ __ ] with so if you're
I'll be like yo they told me I can
[ __ ] play that [ __ ] you interviewing
me all right all right that's what we're
starting the [ __ ] episode off with me
that's how it's gonna open okay the
contract opening up all right to make up
for this [ __ ] all right I promise I'll
be a gamer again I'll get more on it I
appreciate you man thank you so much oh
yeah guys thank you so much for being
here this has been another episode of
the dope as usual podcast solo
gamechanger.com don't forget thank you
guys so much for being here Marty thank
you Marty Marty thank you sir thank you
so much for being here yes sir all right
guys have a dope ass day have a dope ass
day yeah dude this this is gonna be yeah
I'm gonna get y'all the books like I
said it'll be a few days uh
GameStop bro Game Stop This is well it's
gonna be everywhere bro because they not
playing man Rockstar when they get
behind something
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
foreign
[Music]